or more the operation to find survivors
has gone on through the night rescue
teams had to smash through windows to
reach trapped passengers so many stood
little chance of survival as the Train
buckland when it rounded a bend at speed
eight carriages thrown from the rails
some left piled up on top of each other
[Music]
distressed relatives waiting for
passengers could scarcely believe what
was happening a quiet corner of
northwestern Spain in just a few minutes
it became assumed one of Europe's worst
ever rail disasters firefighters called
office tried to join the rescue with
hundreds on board it was a complex
operation trying to reach passengers
some with horrific injuries rescue teams
had to clamber down bags to get to the
Train
hospital staff many operating on reduced
salaries because of spending cuts turned
into tend the injured around 140 people
needed medical treatment the train had
been packed it was taking people to a
Christian festival when it derailed I
heard an explosion and when I arrived
one of the carriages was already over
the road that comes out from there the
neighbors all came over but we began to
get scared because one of the firemen
said it might explode
so we retreated but then it was okay so
we went back clinics were overwhelmed
with people offering to give blood hotel
rooms offered to relatives who'd gone to
the area the dead taken to a local
spirits Hall officials have ruled out a
terrorist link to the incident but are
investigating how fast the train was
traveling the train was carrying two
hundred and forty seven passengers
according to our numbers the derailment
was very violent a train carriage landed
on another track but at the moment we
still don't know what caused it the Pope
has offered prayers for the dead and
injured an investigation into the cause
of the crash is now underway he saw
Holland sky Lewis